e aí
oi e aí galera beleza olha só seria uma
ironia da minha parte começar a falar de
democracia sem ser democrático concordo
já é uma pergunta que vale ouro aqui
porque eles são essa história concordo
beleza então quero propor a vocês que a
gente faça uma democracia real aqui que
a gente volte a gente pensa junto antes
de começar e essa decisão muito
importante porque se vocês decidirem não
ele vai ser um dos testes mais curto a
história vai durar um minuto se vocês
querem sim eu prometo que vai ser um dos
testes mais legais isso ai beleza vamos
juntos então eu quero perguntar para
vocês vocês topam fazer uma coisa comigo
para que a gente saia daqui eleitores
mais conscientes não respondo tocam tão
ótimo ó
e agora que eu voltar olha a eleição ela
é secreta públicas fecham os olhos por
gentileza fecha os olhos quando eu
perguntar vocês vão levantar levemente
as mãos uma delas para quem concorda e
quem não concorda mantém as mãos começar
quem tá de olho aberto aí já é meio ó
segura vamos lá senhoras e senhores
vocês aceitam sair daqui mais
conscientes do que entraram levanta as
mãos que sim
a briga a gente esse sonho ted valeu até
a próxima da mentira caraca foi a minha
idade que legal que legal isso é muito
bom é bom porque eu estou aqui não foi
uma palestra mas para uma provocação
para a gente entender que o nosso espaço
como cidadão é extremamente importante a
democracia não tô aqui para falar de
política é um pouquinho para falar de
partidos tô aqui para falar do nosso
papel na democracia preparados bora para
falar em democracia 4.0 preciso começar
lá no 1.0 porque senão a história fica
incompleta 1.0 eu quero levar vocês dois
milênios atrás lá para apenas apólice em
que cada um daquele cidadão e até a
praça pública para debater era o estilo
da democracia e era assim cada um dizia
o que pensava cada um dizia qual o
destino que gostaria que apólice legal
não é concordam
e com cola
eu concordo galera beleza legal agora
imagina você sim uma cidade com 100 mil
habitantes fosse de bater um a um
durante sei lá uma praça no estádio é
vai no estádio e cada um tivesse um
minuto para falar cada um tivesse um
minutinho para falar sobre a sua opinião
a respeito daquela cidade cara se as
pessoas não fosse ao banheiro não
comecem não dormir e sem nem gás gás em
a gente levasse lá 70 dias posso se
tornar inviável democracia direta e aí
nós passamos para democracia
representativa que aquela que nós
estamos hoje inseridos ou seja nós
elegemos um representante que vai até um
parlamento e lá decide sobre a gente
decide sobre a nossa vida será que esse
camarada essa senhorita que você
oi gê um dia está alinhada com seu
propósito lá volta naquilo que você
gostaria que ele voltasse
ah pois é essa essa é a chave dessa
dessa seção que eu quero fazer com vocês
hoje e aí nós passamos da 2.0 para 3.0
pode que maravilha
e ao longo da da história nós tivemos um
hiato democrático no brasil passou por
isso passamos aproximadamente 29 anos de
período ditatorial em que nós vamos
podíamos escolher os nossos
representantes e naquele momento era um
que tinha voz e nós não temos voz
democracia demo é povo kratos é poder ou
seja o poder do povo o período de
redemocratização passa a ser muito
importante por isso porque nós
resgatamos a voz para poder escolher o
nosso representante para que ele pudesse
então escolher por nossa então um ano de
1989 é muito importante para o brasil é
um momento em que nós nos
redemocratização us
e a foto talvez represente algumas
outras situações hoje em dia mas na
época era uma certeza esperança era uma
certeza de futuro e foi isso aconteceu
não é ou não não muito legal mas a
política passa por isso nem sempre
aquele representante que nós colhemos
cumprir com o combinado com a gente
e ele promete mas nem sem comp mas
independente disso o que importa
realmente é que o povo brasileiro voltou
a reassumir a sua autonomia teve voz
novamente ou como dizem voltou a ser
protagonista na série que foi só no
brasil não isso foi no mundo e eu quero
trazer exemplo pra vocês da alemanha
muro de berlim 1989 alemanha dividida ao
meio bem lindo devido ao meio berlim era
dois países o lado ocidental lado
oriental o lado oriental soviético o
lado ocidental capitalista liderado pelo
pelos americanos e aí numa fala muito
importante ronaldo william que era o
presidente americano de seguinte senhor
gorbachev que era o primeiro-ministro
ali ético derrubar este muro
e aí ele foi lá aí
e não fez nada quem derrubou o povo
alemão o povo alemão assim como o povo
brasileiro voltou a ser protagonista
voltou a ter voz e aí nós precisamos
fazer um a seguinte reflexão esse muro
caiu
tá mas e o muro que divide o povo e o
governo será que ele caiu
e o muro entre governo e cidadão
e me parece me parece que ainda existe
mas eu quero tirar a prova com vocês de
nós vamos para a nossa segunda rodada de
votos estão preparados o voto é secreto
a gente vai fechar hoje de novo beleza
então vamos lá fez 21 entrou na cabine
eleitoral que significa fechar os olhos
fecham os olhos por gentileza ea
pergunta é a seguinte você se lembra em
quem votou para vereador quem lembra por
gentileza levante a mão
um ok pode abaixar como consultar aqui
agora o data ted pra gente só para ter
um pronto aí deu certo 82 ponto sete
porcento não se lembra
e rápido o pessoal saúde para o nosso da
técnica aqui que sensacional incrível
muito rápido resultado em tempo real não
sei nem toda vez legal 82 ponto 7 é
muita gente que não se lembra é muita
gente vamos para para uma segunda
tentativa
essa é a última juro que vou fechar os
olhos tá para que ninguém durma feche os
olhos a última vez senhoras e senhores
vocês se lembram em quem votaram para
deputado estadual por gentileza levante
a mão quem se lembra
o ok obrigado consultar o dated parece
howarth consultando dated ok resultado
deu certo 94.3 por cento senhoras e
senhores
eu acredito nós estejamos muito distante
dos representantes
é é muita gente que não lembra mas eu
tenho a última pergunta não se a fechar
os olhos vocês confio nesses dados foram
apresentados aqui mas alguém que
fiscalizou isso é igual a gente faça
igualzinho a gente passa perante os
nossos representantes nós não
oficializamos e aí enquanto vocês
estavam aqui nesse momento o pessoal da
tec e tirou uma foto e tá ali vocês é
esse é o retrato fiel
e essa essa senhorita matriz swot sair
um filme e ela representa muito bem a
nossa situação atual referente a
democracia nós estamos de olhos vendados
para democracia é tão interessante que
eu vou usar esse paralela aqui nesse
estilo você tem uma roda de conversa
então com os amigos em e tal o cara
democracia sai da roda as suas ainda
roda em vão continuar saindo se nós
continuarmos cegos para ela e aí eu
quero começar essa reflexão com vocês o
4.0 partir do seguinte pressuposto 4.0
de sua opção inovação tecnologia
automação
e eu fui buscar no contexto do estudo do
mestrado aplicativos que teriam
aplicações práticas para conectar
representantes e representados governo
cidadão povo em estado mas como a gente
estava cego ou seja uma deficiência
visual eu fui buscar um aplicativo que
ajuda deficientes visuais vocês conhecem
obi + obb mais é um aplicativo que já
veio no palco como eixo nupex para se
apresentar é um cidadão chamado hans
muller que tem apenas cinco por cento da
sua visão
oi e ele incomodado com essa situação de
ter que pedir para as pessoas ajudas
ajuda para tarefas fáceis ele falou cara
eu posso usar a tecnologia para isso e
ele tem o aplicativo demais que a
senhora e senhores podem baixar agora
por exemplo em ser voluntários para
pessoas que não têm a visão ou seja bem
mais seja meus olhos e aí esse
aplicativo é tão interessante que para
uma atividade muito simples como por
exemplo um deficiente visual tem três
notas na mão uma de 50 uma de 10 mais de
20 ele precisa sair para comprar pão
para ficar ideias reais ele chama no
aplicativo alguém atende e diz para ele
ele falou assim olha eu queria uma ajuda
para saber qual dessas três notas é a
dia essa que você falou bote a sua mão
na mesa vai até o centro é essa você
acabou de pegar nota de 10 pode ir
comprar o seu pão olha que coisa simples
é uma outra pessoa que enxerga pode
fazer mas quem decisão não pode fazer
ela não tem como saber pelo tato qual
nota é a de nessa agora olha que
interessante como um aplicativo que hoje
conta com dois milhões de voluntários
como eu eu sou um desses voluntários
pode ajudar mais de 150.000 cegos ou
deficientes visuais se assim preferir
que estão cadastrados se se o meu
celular tocar agora e eu não puder
atender tem mais um milhão 999077 que
nós criamos uma conexão e criamos uma
comunidade para colaborar a favor do
próximo interessante não é
é essa eu vou fazer de olhos abertos
quem tem um smartphone aqui por
gentileza levanto amor
eu vou consultar o da ted para a última
vez 99.9 por cento você me levanto a mão
porque o seu aquele nokia de lanterninha
ainda você não considerou que ele seja
um smartphone legal não se preocupe mas
aqui nós temos a reflexão apesar da
piada sem graça
e nem toda a população brasileira está
conectada
e nós temos hoje 209 milhões de pessoas
no brasil e nós temos hoje 230 milhões
de aparelhos celulares tá sobrando
aparelho mas tem muitos em poucas mãos
e hoje tem gente que não tem nem o que
comer e não tem nem o que beber que não
dorme numa casa ela vai se preocupar em
ter um celular
e não mas se a gente começar a pensar
coletivamente nós podemos nos conectar a
um representante público para fazer com
que mais e mais pessoas têm o que comer
onde dormir e o que beber ou seja nós
somos parte dessa mudança ou seja é hora
a senhora e senhores de democratizar a
democracia
e parece uma frase legal e até capô
fônica mas eu juro para vocês que é algo
que nós precisamos ser parte se 99.9 por
cento dessa plateia tem um celular em
mãos se 99.9 por cento assustam esse
vídeo agora tem um celular em mãos elas
podem ser parte dessa democratização da
democracia então a gente precisa
entender que o papel mais importante na
democracia é o do cidadão ou seja o meu
o seu o seu o seu e nós não podemos mais
negligenciar isso as eleições acontecem
de dois em dois anos e nós não podemos
esperar mais 20 mais 30 uma aquele ato
que eu mostrei pra vocês para começarmos
a nos mexer
oi e aí eu entro na parte final da minha
reflexão excitex ele é fruto de uma tese
de mestrado e para evitar que vocês
lessem 120 páginas eu vou resumir em
dois minutos o que aconteceu
e este é o mapa da gestão digital que em
colaboração com meu orientador nós
desenvolvemos para elencar em alguns
pontos aonde se encaixavam oito
aplicativos de gestão pública no brasil
são eles meu vereador nosso mandato
collab monitória brasil em gp meu
deputado poder do voto e mudamos mais
talvez alguns de vocês aqui até os
conheça até os use e aí foram dois anos
estudando essa história para entender a
capacidade que cada um desse aplicativo
tinha de conectar cover e cidadão e aí o
mais interessante de tudo
e é que o fracassei
há dois anos estudando para descobrir
que ali naquele cantinho que representa
o cenário ideal tá vazio
em nenhum dos aplicativos estudados
durante dois anos conseguiram atingir o
índice da gestão sócio digital
e nenhum e aí senhoras e senhores eu
poderia ter desanimado entregue meu
trabalho agradecido e cruzar os braços
mas não eu fui procurar um dos palcos
mais conhecidos do mundo chamado tex
para provocar pessoas como você
e a pensar na possibilidade de
desenvolver um aplicativo desse nós
vamos precisar de programadores nós
vamos precisar de engenheiros
professores desempregados têm mais
arquitetos eles vão precisar de pintores
nós vamos precisar de entusiastas para
que isso possa acontecer sabe porque se
a chance para que aqueles que não tem
hoje a capacidade de ter um smartphone
mãos para acompanhar um representante
posso amanhã tenho que comer onde dormir
e como sobreviver e aí a gente vai
entender aquela primeira pergunta que eu
fiz para vocês se nós podemos ser mais
conscientes porque um eleitor consciente
um indivíduo consciente e um cidadão
consciente mete medo em qualquer
governante muito obrigado tá
e aí